hi Ariela Shapiro High Point University
no relation I have been asked like 16
times by my face so my question is well
we can pretend an annual and what they
say that I should pretend like oh you
should tell him tell people that you're
related to him I'm like I think he knows
who he's related to I feel like you're
that kind of person um so my question
was a little bit more lighthearted I
guess um so based off of just cardi B
and the video that and their DUI tax
here oh yeah she should be everyone's
tax hero if we take what she said in
that video I member President she's my
secretary of the Treasury so my question
is um kind of going off of that and her
sentiment um maybe in a little bit of a
more eloquent fashion do you think that
there is a do you think that the leftist
ideals that have infiltrated and been
pushed by Hollywood and popular media
for however long that's been happening
for do you think that that's changing do
you think that that that we're seeing a
shift because I don't think cardi B
actually realizes that she's not really
a leftist when she says things like
right but because she's obviously in the
she lived the life that she lives she's
associated with the people that she's
associated with she probably doesn't
know how to identify in any other way
yeah so do you think that that's going
to happen dude how long do you think
that's I do think that a lot of the
political barriers are breaking down I
mean as folks in this room know I'm not
a rap fan but but but yeah soft applause
um but by that but you know what Kanye
West did was actually quite brave right
when Kanye came out and he said listen
you can think how you want a thing good
for Kanye West I mean this guy's still a
nutcase but good for him
it's but the I mean go read his old
tweets about four pillows and fish tanks
but is it but is there there is a new
generation of people in Hollywood we
don't feel like they got there by
accident and who feel like they've
worked very hard for their money and
when they look at their tax bill they're
going wait a second
why am I supposed to feel guilty about
earning a lot of money when I was
working at a coffee bean as a barista
three years ago and I worked my tail off
and I wrote scripts in my spare time and
now the government's gonna take 50% of
my
so yeah there's an innate rebellion
that's happening against some of this
stuff also I think that some of the test
cases for the left in Hollywood have
sort of dissipated in terms of
importance so for example five years ago
the big thing in Hollywood was if you
were against same-sex marriage you could
not work in Hollywood like you could not
work in Hollywood now obviously since
oberst felt there's not much than
anybody can do about the issue of
same-sex marriage I've been libertarian
on same-sex marriage since I think 2012
not because I am a morally in favor of
same-sex marriage but because I don't
think that the government has a place in
the sphere right I never thought the
government had a place in this fear
generally because the government sucks
at everything and when I married my wife
I didn't do it for the tax discount
right right there is actually in spoiler
alert there's no tax discount but it's
it but since that has sort of been
alleviated there is a libertarian rise
in Hollywood particularly young
Hollywood folks that's kind of a sound
thing like I've been kind of shocked
actually at the number of relatively
major stars whose names that you would
know who listen to show and and who have
actually visited our offices under cover
of darkness and whose names I will not
mention because apparently if you say
you should follow me on Twitter now and
did you see that thing that happened a
couple of weeks ago and it was just wild
right where that this is this director
this indie director named Mark Duplass
he came into our office he hung out
there for like an hour and a half asking
me questions about gun control and I was
nice to him then he tweeted out you know
it appears a nice guy you might want to
get my follow on Twitter and the entire
world caved in on him and he deleted the
tweet and then he apologized for it
saying I was a racist sexist bigoted
homophobe and in the in the maoist
apology terminology and then somehow
James Gunn got involved and then James
Gunn ended up being fired which which
does confirm my theory that I'm
basically Thanos and that by
and that almost literally by sitting
there and snapping my fit in my fingers
I can make half the MCU disappear but
it's but it's but it is the level
intolerance is exactly the same as it
ever was in Hollywood but there's a
group of young people who are looking at
politics right now and they feel adrift
they don't feel at home in the
Democratic Party which is increasingly
radical and insane and they don't feel
at home and the Republican Party mainly
because a lot of them don't like
President Trump very much so it's I
think that that's creating some openings
there there's some political
realignments that are underway that are
kind of fascinating